that was the late side of the recording
welcome to this video playing Moscow
plush soup something um okay I tried
something else now I usually have the
snake benoni against him but why not
something else I mean the maroc see with
white how a nice can it get pretty high
rating at the mode the sky a queen 85
that is a well-known line that is some
bit tricky for black to play is it 95
here I always I always forget this it's
been a while since I looked at this and
even the should have 695 is interesting
what you came
kd3 here or f3 probably d3c going 97
maybe
yeah that early f5 admitted since always
oh it's am a bit a bit of a double
double edge decision because of the
square said white is giving up but you
get some play on the kingside in return
no I'm threatening be form winning a
piece be 497 be five traps the bishop or
be 49 a 6b five is a fork
it's not so clear how stable those
pieces are maybe a five is an idea just
blocking everything yeah that makes lots
of sense actually okay
so look g3 on an h4 probably i'll do a
take g6 first and then root G 34 or 35
he's got 96 but the some invites other
ideas like rook f1 look at five hmm wow
it's not reacting to it at all we go a
cure for cancer this is the idea okay
let's jump into t5 look at b6 cover f4
there is some pieces on e5 and see if I
they look nice but his king is not that
great who says you have to react to
things who has ever said that so I'm
going to go rogue g5 that was the main
idea actually covering a form or am i
overlooking stuff so he wants to play
fancy fancy stuff
alright so that's a bit of an issue age
3 is not helping a rogue f1
took me a while to spot that move
soon what what the heck what is
happening here if I take with the bishop
UWE tick with the Queen odd
look 592 what now that's never going to
work here never but refuting it is a
different animal how to refute that hi
Morgan there should be four Queen you
for see no refutation Riley the time
takes down okay anyway that is not the
refutation but I needed to play
something ultimately well it's not ideal
really not but yeah time was check
ticking down you are seriously
check yeah a position is just good for
me but time time time time time diamond
okay Bishop to g4 and the deep porn
would be nice Bishop g4 possibly look c6
this would be good good to get in I know
he's taking some time
sponsor a bit more advanced in mine
check that be one yeah III I am what a
frustrating game jack good totally
irritated by this stuff check check
okay well I is deeply annoying okay so
you started this trickery and it just
irritated me far too much I mean black
it's just entitled shape here so let's
see what happens room g5 Luke f8 kingi
wanna that took far too long I really
have no other move and this year so how
do I refute this Bishop divorce
Winningham I mean there is a winning
that's pretty clear jeez I just didn't
see it ninety-seven huh because now g6
is hanging and it could never work
really never and it didn't work but i
didn't i didn't see it so you can play
any kind of crap if the other side is
not seeing it 97 wins now ok because
rook g6 was such a big threat when I
didn't see it I simply didn't see it I
mean this was just going into an equal
endgame and check way I'm letting miss
plate and now here this is winning for
me I just have to be precise yeah Bishop
g4 already a stupid I just should take
this and yeah it's more less winning but
still have to do it in 20-something
seconds guy this is a case where already
handed him that game on a silver plate
very very simply ah stupid stuff this is
in particular can still do look everyone
but I just played like it complete [ __ ]
when had no time on the clock I mean he
I'm probably losing already but yeah it
was difficult to reduce the game if you
have to click play extremely badly to do
it but I managed okay thanks for
watching